I have a little bit of a game for you
guys game it's a movie version of would
you rather so picking it between one
answer or the other and briefly
explaining why we choose it so first off
would you rather work opposite an actor
who prepares way way too much we're not
nearly enough not nearly enough I think
the two miles
it's hardly much yeah as if it's an
experienced actor too much no sorry if
it's an experienced really really you
know experienced have been doing it for
years they're not much but if it's
someone who doesn't have much experience
that you know you want them to have done
their homework
I almost feel the opposite I feel like
if I'm working with an experienced actor
I don't really mind if he's done no prep
because I think I trust that he can walk
in and do it oh yeah wait yeah that's
what you just said okay yeah we're on
the same page it makes a whole lot of
sense would you rather have to do a
scene where you're running throughout
the entire scene or eating the entire
scene running running running I love
running eating and I hate taking those
like small little bites that you have to
take I did a Thanksgiving dinner scene
in a movie last year and I I never want
to eat Thanksgiving dinner again now
yeah I ate a bag of plantain chips in
the scene recently and you know three
hours in okay we're going again you're
like yeah it's the best piece of advice
that someone can another fellow actor
can give you when you're doing a scene
is like don't eat too much because the
first movie I did I would take like a
big mouthful and then I had to keep
taking a big mouthful then I think I
even Hawke told me we were all sitting
around having a Thanksgiving dinner in
this thing for a whole day and he's like
Laila don't just I'll just stop eating
the food stop eating so much bread
because you're gonna have to eat all
that bread you're gonna be sick into
your napkin speaking of being sick this
is my favorite question cuz it stresses
me out would you rather have to fake
sneeze or fake vomit and see me
Oh vomit I draw the fake vomit how do
you feel like it would be survive I
don't know how to sake sneeze it's such
a like I think he's retching would make
me really red
I was doing a send I was doing some
additional dialogue you know
post-production and they're like okay
for this bit you know you've just been
hit by this big blast of a wave and so
we did a couple of takes of it and
sounded exactly like a sneeze is that
Geo storm that was this oh and when you
get hit by a wave like around Shang whoa
oh oh and they were like that sounded a
bit too like a sneeze to be honest can
we do it again like why does it say you
love it when they're brutally honest
with you you're like that sounded crap
yeah would you rather work on location
or on a soundstage
oh it depends if it's freezing outside I
don't like the cold but then sometimes
the sound stages are freezing as well
yeah it's so dependent I'm gonna say
look if it's Hawaii
take me there yeah I think location
there because it's nice to be able to
like travel around and and see the world
we're so lucky that we get to do that
yeah you know I hear Wellington is not a
bad place to be beautiful it's so
beautiful and enjoy wilt I was in a
soundstage every day except for one
scene though that oh yeah that don't
want that see yeah yeah where you're
climbing up on the rubble yeah we
Wellington is a fantastic city also this
the windiest city in the world factually
I know they call it windy what is it
yeah I wouldn't be surprised you'd be
walking down the street and like it
would be push the wind would push you
faster it would make a good traction
city actually because they'd be like we
could just just drive it over yeah
for sales yeah windy Wellington would
have big mass
[Music]